[Musique]
retrouvailles avec les copines qu'elle
m'a même pas dit bonjour est ce que vous
dites non je veux mettre chez colas
m'énerver passion passion beaucoup mais
en même temps mais j'adore ses limites
de l'émission pays bichard cas où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à tous merci à tous merci beaucoup
d'une petite bande à haut débit
mis à mal
[Rires]
bi aujourd'hui premier cours on va à
l'école
tiens on va là l'école bah oui on va
aller au cours d'eau paysage
bon sinon tu vas apprendre à ne plus
manger les autres chiens
et puis tu vas apprendre un appareil à
ne plus fumer parce qu'on a ça suffit de
partir et de parvenir
donc on va faire des petits cours j'ai
près tueur est sage tu avais pas obéir
bah c'est pas gagné et je veux tu en
voilà
là mais là le dimanche matin sous la
couette et voilà et voilà oh là là rien
belle au château et ses nouveaux filtres
est un chat tu as eu pas mal attentes se
montre franchement ce que dirait bien
pas besoin pien mme hachem kia ont fait
six morts à neutre je suis chiens qui
jonchent fait pas d'études du deuil
je dis merci à tous un tournage des
mines émission c à 17h45 ce soir
[Musique]